Chúng em hi hai thằng chiến tất giạng sáng ngày 12 thằng chiến dường hành lối
Đại huy động lấy thập quốc khoảng tạm mới
Đà thung khoảng tuyên bụn như yó về giải quyết phò bình bình đề
và lấy pháp thằng nhà nước
Tình bụn nhận được một trong bướng hai phở thuật
Bởi phở trọng và mởi hai phở trọng
Bởi vì yếu sởi ràng năm trong gọng phà đối
Pân kẻ này gió pháp và rập xíu đồng bảo trợ
Cứ định cậu bất cụ thể để hiện thực phó bình bình bựng
Chúng em hiểu giữa israny và palestine
Tuyên bụn kèo gọi người bánh nơi đập tức tại giải gà ra
Chả từ gió cho các con tín thành lập một nhà nước palestine
Đập lập có chục quên
Đông thời gian thống như thúc đầy bị thử hóa quan hệ
Giờ israny và giới à rập
Lộ trình cụt đề cập đến giải giáp nhóm vụ trạng hà mắt
Thế lập một phai bộ của tế tạm thời gian giới sự bảo trợ của liên hình cố
Nhằm bảo vệ giận thường palestine
Giám sát nừng bản và hỗ trợ giải gọi hậu xung đột tại giải gà ra
Tổng thức kỳ là của Antonio Woodress hàng định
Giải pháp hành nơi nơi đường đảng cố lỗi của sĩnh chim hoặc bình Trung đông
Bởi mục tiêu người israny và người palestine cụt đề cung trung sống trong khoa bình và an ninh
Fio palestine có kết quả bỏ phíau là thẳng lựng ngoại giao
Phó tổng thẳng hú sên á sĩnh nhìn mạnh
Đây là ý chi của tế uống hộ quyền của người dân palestine
Và là bức tiến quan trọng hướng tới việc chấm rất chim đống
Thang lập nhả nước đặc lập với đông dưu xa lệm đặt thử dô
Và ta cùng nhiều cua ra á rập hôn ngành nghỉ
Còn đây là cột mốt quan trọng khủng cụ giải pháp hành nơi nơi
Bình bú giải bày trang là kết quả hồ nghỉ của tế giò á rập dựu
Tại pháp tổ chức tại liên hộ của tự thẳng bầy
Đư đình ra cầu ý nghĩa chính trị lớn, dù không mạng tình dạng bở pháp li